une salle désespérément vides et qui
devrait le rester encore un peu
vraisemblablement avec la crise
sanitaire ce resteront ne sera pas
autorisée à rouvrir avant la fin de
l'année un nouveau coup dur pour le
secteur
j'ai allumé la radio ce matin j'ai
entendu ça j'ai su arrêter dans la
voiture j'avais presse-purée un grand
coup c'est une prise d'otage quand on
comprend pas très bien les choses on ne
les explique pas tout façon c'est
quelque chose qui nous tombe sur la tête
qui nous assomme selon nos confrères de
france info
le gouvernement pencherait pour une
reprise des restaurants et bars le 15
janvier une date que ces professionnels
jurassien juge trop lointaines
d'autant plus que leur établissement
affiche est déjà quasiment complet pour
le réveillon et tous les clients qui
sont la réservation qu'il va falloir en
rappel pour annuler tous ces gens si
réservé pour le 31 on arrive en plus sur
le mois de décembre c'est la fin du
trimestre des charges sociales moi mon
wii qui ment mon premier de l'an avec
mom et groupes avaient tout ça si vous
voulez ça ça pallier à toutes mes
charges paye toutes mes charges avec ces
trucs là aujourd'hui mais je vais me
retrouver avec trois mois de chercheurs
donnent au 10 janvier
je sais pas comment je vais faire à
métabief
l'inquiétude grandit aussi car ici la
saison hivernale est cruciale on va dire
que si on travaille par décembre janvier
et février on perd quasiment 50% de
notre chiffre d'affaires
si c'est pas 60 tous les villages aux
alentours on travaille tous grâce à la
neige grâce à la station donc si elle
n'était pas ouverte en février je pense
qu'on irait une catastrophe
le premier ministre jean castex devrait
s'exprimer sur le sujet d'ici la fin du
mois